crees que todas las calculadoras en el
mismo resultado para la misma operación
verifiquemos con unos ejemplos muy
sencillos saca tu calculadora una hoja y
un lápiz
puedes pasar el vídeo para ir a
conseguirlos pero si no los tienes a la
mano
pon mucha atención para que practiques
después
tenemos la operación 5 + 9 x 6
qué resultados de en tu calculadora
puede ser 59 84 pero hoy como bien sabes
no puede haber dos resultados correctos
sólo uno es válido anota tu resultado
ahora introduce en tu calculadora a la
siguiente operación 3
más 24 por 7 y los resultados pueden ser
33 o 63 nuevamente solo uno es correcto
otro más
2 - 3 al cuadrado cuánto te dio menos 7
o 1 como te puedes dar cuenta las
calculadoras nos pueden dar resultados
muy distintos pero al realizar
operaciones matemáticas sólo 1 es el
correcto el tener resultados diferentes
no significa que una calculadora esté
defectuosa y la otra no simplemente
existen calculadoras jerárquicas y otras
elementales
si al realizar las operaciones
anteriores sus resultados fueron 84 63 y
1 estos no son correctos debido a que
tienes una calculadora elemental es
decir solo efectúa cálculos de
operaciones según el orden en el que
teclea se introducen los datos de
izquierda a derecha por el contrario se
obtuviste 5933 en -7 los resultados son
correctos tu calculadora es jerárquica o
sea establece un orden interno similar
al algebraico para realizar la operación
recuerda que existe algo que se llama
jerarquía de operaciones en la cual
primero se realizan las operaciones
exponenciales luego multiplicaciones y
divisiones y finalmente sumas y restas
todo esto siempre de izquierda a derecha
así que para no confiarnos completamente
de una calculadora independientemente de
si es elemental o jerárquica aprendamos
a introducir los datos para que los
resultados que nos dé sean los correctos
veamos cómo hacerlo tenemos la siguiente
operación
+ 4 por 16 entre dos más tres al
cuadrado pausa el vídeo te reto a que
los resuelvas mentalmente y después lo
verifiquemos con la calculadora qué
resultado obtuviste para verificarlo en
la calculadora debemos introducir
algunos signos que nos ayudarán a
jerarquizar la operación fíjate muy bien
si tu calculadora tiene paréntesis y una
función como x al cuadrado introduce los
datos de la siguiente manera
+ paréntesis otra vez paréntesis 4 por
16 paréntesis diagonal que es el signo
de dividir 2
cierro paréntesis + paréntesis
presionamos la tecla x al cuadrado y
cerramos paréntesis seguro en tu
calculadora se ve así
al presionar el signo de igual el
resultado que obtendrá es 44 en este
caso los paréntesis de la calculadora
nos ayudaron a separar las operaciones y
a crear quitarlas de manera automática
en caso de que tu calculadora no tenga
estas funciones como tendríamos que
realizar la operación lo que debemos
hacer es jerarquizar la operación
nosotros mismos e introducirla en el
orden correcto la primera operación que
realizamos es 3 al cuadrado en la
calculadora introducimos 3 por 3 y el
resultado es 9 ese 9 lo guardaremos
tantito podemos apuntar en una hoja
ahora multiplicamos 4 por 16 y nos da 64
el 64 lo dividimos entre el siguiente
número o sea 2 y obtenemos 32 apuntamos
en nuestra hoja el 32 ya que
desaparecimos el exponente las
multiplicaciones y divisiones sólo nos
queda sumar 3 más 32 más 9 y eso es
igual a 44 viste que la calculadora o su
paréntesis junto con la jerarquía de
operaciones y que nosotros lo hicimos
manualmente si no lo hiciéramos de esta
manera y resolviéramos la operación de
corrido el resultado sería incorrecto y
muy diferente al 44 mira 3 + 4 es igual
a 7 por 16 112 entre 256 más 3 al
cuadrado que es 9 es igual a 65 así que
sea cual sea tu calculadora ya sabes
cómo introducir las operaciones sigue
practicando